producing a fool squeezing and squeezing
that's not how it's being seen that is
how it is and I will not accept it
the popular Netflix series the crown
showed how Graham Sutherlands portrait
of Winston Churchill may have been
destroyed it's just one example of how
great pieces of art have been lost over
time whether they were intentionally
destroyed or stolen or the result of an
accident art historian no attorney
details at all in the museum of lost art
we spoke to him at the gagauzian gallery
here in New York they went upstairs and
I saw the sculpture and pieces all over
the floor
Carolyn Richard alley will never forget
the day in 2002 when a sculpture named
Adam took a terrible fall he was in 28
large pieces and hundreds of small
pieces it's a crime scene
it was the conservator for the
Metropolitan Museum of Art says the
six-foot-three Adam was gravely damaged
after his plywood pedestal buckled this
piece is one of the most important
sculptures from the early Renaissance
certainly in the Western Hemisphere
outside of Italy and when something like
this breaks it's we we couldn't accept
the loss Adam is one of the pieces
author and art historian Noah Charney
examined in his new book about the
vulnerability of the world's treasures
what would a museum of lost art look
like how big would it be well it would
be bigger than all the museum's of the
world combined and it would have works
by every artist you've heard of because
there really isn't an artist to exist
who doesn't have works that are lost
take 15th century painter Roger Vander
Heiden we focus on his deposition
painting which is a very beautiful work
it's an all enjoyed art history books in
the Museo del Prado in Madrid right but
during his lifetime there was something
called the justice cycle that was 35
feet long and 12 feet high a series of
four major works that were his his
the big rock star object that he created
but those were burnt in the 17th century
unfortunately so that was the work that
he would have liked us to focus on but
because it doesn't survive we focus on
other works that are also wonderful but
maybe not the most important right some
lost works are due to theft like the 13
masterpieces snatched from Boston's
Isabella Stewart Gardner Museum in 1990
the stolen art is valued at around half
a billion dollars and included a
Rembrandt and Vermeer the theft from the
Gardner Museum took place on st.
Patrick's Day night and two people
dressed as policemen knocked on the
employee entrance and against
regulations the security guards at night
let them in the security guards were
seized and tied up and gagged and put
down in the basement and for about 40
minutes these two thieves went through
the museum and they took thirteen
objects they stomped on certain works of
art that suggest that they were sort of
oblivious to their value but they were
very careful with others and those works
have never been found again it's the big
mystery there's many detectives
proactively looking for there's a five
million dollar reward if you happen to
know where they are and it's it's a
thorn in the side of the FBI and the
investigators because it's been an open
case for so long how big is art theft as
compared to other crimes well few people
realize that art theft has been called
the third highest-grossing criminal
trade worldwide behind only the drug and
arms trades really it's absolutely
enormous and by far the biggest problem
is illicit trade in antiquities and
that's been highlighted in 2015 since
it's been overtly clear that Isis was
making a lot of money by selling looted
antiquities so it also funds terrorism
so whether or not you're an art lover
it's important to take it seriously
long before Isis Charney says there were
other wartime villains far worse
Napoleon who was the first to organize a
special unit of his army that was
dedicated to stealing art and to require
when you had an armistice signing with
him when he stopped shooting at you you
have to give him some of your art as
payment but the Nazis were the biggest
bad guys an estimated 5 million cultural
heritage objects changed hands
inappropriately during the Second World
War
and many thousands of them are still
lost others have been recovered
including some that were hidden in plain
sight like Leonardo da Vinci's Salvator
Mundi it was purchased for 45 pounds in
1958 but nearly 60 years later would
become the most expensive painting ever
sold at auction and the piece is so it
was sold for 450 million dollars and
that's because it was misidentified as a
19th century pastiche based on a loss
Leonardo and it was very dirty it had to
be cleaned provenance research had to be
done to make sure it was the real thing
and then all of a sudden the value
skyrockets and there are countless
stories like this and each one is this
beautiful shining diamond in the sand
that you spot and you cross your fingers
that it's the real deal but it inspires
hope that many of the works that we
think are lost for good might be found
again
so in finding lost art is it more
setting out to do so or is it just luck
everyone wants to be Indiana Jones and I
always want to do this well except for
the snakes except for the snakes the
problem is that a lot of luck is
involved so you can follow trails but so
much of it is buried and has to be
unburied in organized archaeological
expeditions or by chance which can
happen sometimes and you have to steer
very carefully at what's hidden in your
attic or in a dark corner of your house
because you might just have something
very precious there technology like luck
can also play a role using the latest
advancements in detection works we never
knew existed by artists like Goya
Picasso and Malevich have been uncovered
and one of the ways that they can find
lost works is by using different light
spectra to look behind the surface of
works of art and there's these famous
examples of very surprising discoveries
like Kazmir Malevich black square which
is one of the most famous paintings
turns out their two paintings buried
underneath it and looking at it with
special light spectra that lets you look
beneath the surface allows you to not
harm the painting itself but to see
what's lying beneath and for priceless
pieces that suffer damage like atom
resurrection can be possible with years
of painstaking work the most credit
to go to the conservators not only for
their technical skill but for the fact
that they didn't give up on it something
that was in hundreds of splinters you
might throw up your hands and say it's a
lost cause but now it looks as good as
new
a breathtaking example of art saved from
being lost I think in the end he will be
back to where he was so is that the same
we're not that's for everybody else to
decide but I think that the spirit of
the sculpture and the true beauty of it
is still there
[Music]
and add them up close you could maybe
see a line or two but it looked like
nothing had happened maybe a chip here
there but that's part of his history
yeah it sure is
what an incredible what a mobile
restoration that is yeah and and I still
remember that Gardner Museum theft I
mean it's like it was just haunting and
it's still I can't believe they haven't
found it it is surprising they said that
there's so much still out there that's
the only good thing is that it wasn't
destroyed so maybe it is still out there
and somebody will eventually find it